hello and welcome everyone to the lobby
GameSpot's weekly hangout here on
Wednesdays in San Francisco California
I'm your host Mike McCarty here as
always with Peter Brown hey Chum and 2
other guys in black shirt the same black
shirt actually uh Dave Jewett and Oscar
dais I'm like has anyone ever called you
Oscar deus ex uh one very long am I the
one you just killed them yeah sweet well
uh if you can't tell we've got our
international crew in the office this
week these guys came from across the
pond Sunday yeah how was America
treating you so far it's a swine like
jet LAG's kicking my butt yeah
everything you cook and give us just
tastes like sugar really having that me
specifically
I've been cooking yet who can you candy
just be to me like candy sugar uh most
people watching probably know we are
heading down to Los Angeles this weekend
to prepare for III it's that time of
year and if you're joining us in the
YouTube chat twitch chat or on gamespot
we have the chat up in the studio here
as always so we will be here if you have
any comments questions or concerns do
have a giveaway winner announcement we
don't have a giveaway this week but stay
tuned throughout next week for e3 we
have a bunch of giveaways whether you're
watching on our co-op stage or our
editorial stage upstairs we're going to
kind of be announcing them throughout
the week so if you don't follow us on
Twitter make sure you do that because
every once in a while we'll do something
you can retweet and win for instance
last week we announced a pretty good
giveaway it's the razor blade 14 inch
laptop uh we have a winner it is Derek
vaisakhi or Sochi apologies if I'm
butchering that from Massachusetts so
congratulations on that it's a pretty
sweet prize that's a really sweet prize
yeah what'd you say it's like a couple
couple foul I think so but it's not
about the volume legs actually my all
account how much is two thousand dollars
in pounds and five thousand pounds okay
gotcha three thousand seven hundred
right now sweet so it's a 5,000 pound
laptop that Terasaki just one doing a
few news items to get through before
pretty much it's going to go through
each of the six bigger publishers that
were going to be talking about for their
press conferences that are coming up
this weekend early next week
but before we get to that we have a few
news items and
Tendo directed ditto sorry Nintendo did
a Pokemon focus Nintendo Direct
yesterday yeah yesterday and pokken
tournament DX kya
the switch port was announced for
September 22nd you can go check out more
of that on GameSpot we did a few news
stories out of that a Nintendo Direct um
the other big Pokemon news story coming
out of there
I mean Pokemon news story big might be
over selling it so I mean for the
Nintendo Direct any Pokemon news story
is big yeah Oscar you're a huge Pokemon
person right I am yeah
cuz you actually liked Sun and Moon uh
what is a good game that's like I've
been said I liked X&Y they're better I
disagree
yeah I know we did disagree yesterday we
did this is just a repeat of that
argument yeah are you pretty excited for
pokken do you like pokken tournament i
know it's not the same as it was all
right probably like I was I was pretty
disappointed yesterday cuz all the
rumors were pointing to it being Pokemon
stars and then it was like a port of a
fighting game yeah for someone like
myself who doesn't know what Pokemon
stars would be what is it so that was
the it was the rumored third version of
Santa moon that was going to be on the
intended switch ah and it did not happen
well not yet anyway and that was what
everyone thought was going to be
revealed in the direct yesterday yeah
and then what we got was some gold and
silver ports on Virtual Console a
fighting game port and then ultrasone a
moon on intent of 3d s only yeah as how
is that are they making that to coincide
with the crowd buying the what the
enhanced 3s or whatever it is or there
may be a making that purely to Russell
me only reason are slowly rustled yeah
yeah thank you screw that Oscar there's
gonna yep
they're making it cuz it's gonna sell
what one is the best selling thing on
3ds I mean yeah so apparently they have
Pokemon ultrasone and ultramoon have
alternate stories and new Pokemon
because we didn't get enough dumb
Pokemon in Sun and Moon to begin with
you say that babish huh you know I found
at rubbish no the rubbish Pokemon is
just rubbish new Justin in Moon
he's just the wouldn't been around okay
every new Pokemon I caught in sunny
Munoz I just was what am i doing
hawlucha from X&Y yeah the war was II
they got luchador Hawk that yeah [ __ ]
sweets alright they had
Krabbe ruler which was a boxer oh yeah
crab he was one of the greatest Pokemon
ever
he's one of the few good ones so if
you're into Sun and Moon and the idea of
playing one with alternate stories and a
few more Pokemon to catch
I don't mean to just keep kicking while
it's down I'm just kidding I know a lot
of people like that game I just wasn't a
fan uh yeah that was also announced on a
Nintendo Direct and just in just to wrap
up a few reviews that are up now our
arms review for a Nintendo switches up
Kelly plague II wrote it what published
this morning yeah and uh like today like
that I don't know yeah came at the last
minute no I'm kidding I gave it a 7 out
of 10
um pretty fairly novel take on a
fighting game but Nintendo kind of doing
stepping into a genre like they did with
splatoon and saying let's do something
weird with this but yeah a few problems
with it but 7 out of 10 overall a good
game and Tekken 7 Pete you reviewed it
tell us about it
synopsis it's a great fighting game
that's sort of built on the you know
every Tekken that's come before it with
a few tweaks it's missing some of the
things that you know used to make a
Tekken home port like feel maybe bigger
than its arcade version and it's
stripped away all tutorials so for all
the new mechanics it introduces and the
old ones that people may not know you're
kind of left to your own to figure it
out which is not a sin but it's
something that other fighting users have
kind of figured out at this point so
it's disappointing to see from Tekken
considering that this game came out in
the arcades a couple years ago and I've
had a lot of time to work on it but
still a great fighting game I would
totally recommend it it's it's one of my
favorite fighting games of the moment so
cool and as I said people joining live
that review is up as is the arms of you
you can go check both and the wipeout
omega collection if you want to go check
those out that we gave and 9 9 out of 10
points so pretty what faithful homage to
the old older games well so it takes the
last three games and just surprises them
one of them was a Vita game so that's
kind of the most significant inclusion
in the package yeah yeah prettied up
versions of decent wipeout stuff cool so
if you want to go catch up on our
reviews from recent games before we get
into e3 the hectic chaos of III you go
check those out on games by right now
but let's get into the main segments for
today we're gonna go publisher by
publisher for the big ones I realized
that that's not the only thing going on
at e3 but those easiest ones to break
down and
the ones that have press conference
coming up this weekend and early next
week
so we're going to cycle through we have
a just mcdonald and crowd from the
Australia office coming in as well as
Lucy James and Tamar Hussein will be
closing out the show but first Oscar and
Dave I want to talk to you guys about ei
what we know we'll be there
what we hope will be there and what
could possibly be there based on rumors
and whatnot uh first off I think the
bigger one is Battlefront 2 I believe
that's the poster on the fig right now
the iconic spot for e3 Figaro hotel is
at it yeah yeah that's just it's the
what it's a place where everyone in the
gang shoes oh so it's all meet up at the
fig no no that's not what I'm talking
about it all I don't I don't I'm not
part of that crew I'm just saying that's
the hotel that always has the massive
poster on it outside oh okay
yes Ted put me down and oh so sensitive
so the main post wall uh in other news
the God of War poster went up today we
can get into that later with Sony went
to more Lucy come on but Jeff Keeley
announcers like an hour long I got a war
panels segment III Coliseum this year
yeah um but yeah the battlefront 2 is
the main like giant poster thing up
outside of the LA Convention Center so
we'll see that do you think do you think
they'll focus more on this like a story
mode that we've been seeing so much
thank you John Luke see that's the three
building kind of thing uh yeah do you
guys think they're gonna do you think
they're gonna show for Battlefront more
you think they'll show like multiplayer
single-player focus on the single-player
like they seem to have been doing
I think they've said they're gonna show
of 20 versus 20 multiplier battle Naga
Naboo but I mean I would have thought
we'd see some single-player stuff as
well yeah it seems to be their focus so
far and I think a lot of people
complained that the first one didn't
have that I'd be surprised if they
didn't say make a big show of them
having that this time round even though
I didn't I don't really care that
there's a single-player
well the single-player is like so much
different so there's it's not a single
player like that has ever really been in
a Star Wars game it's from the Imperial
point of view and showing a completely
different sides to the Star Wars
universe and it feels like it's filling
in some gaps that the movies have let
you see in this in Australia you see
like the Death Star blow up so you're
getting to all those big pivotal moments
that you see in the film you're getting
to see like the aftermath for like the
smaller smaller guys mm-hmm which is
something like that's that's the main
draw for me just
having that so is universe but seeing
different different points of view
through it yeah for sure and did you
guys enjoy the 2015 Battlefront I did
for a time but I when it when it
launches news exciting it was getting
back into that Star Wars universe the
might player was it was good for time
and and the little nuances that the dice
always nail like like sound design and
the the level design were always great
but as as it went on it felt rather than
balancing the game more it became more
unbalanced and more unfriendly to new
players and each game became more of a
chore and a frustration but when it
released it was it felt more fluid
because everyone's on the same playing
field but after a few updates and few
new weapons I just left it because it
got to the point where everyone every
Imperial trooper was the same everywhere
war troop was the same and it just got
really tight so I hope that's something
that I'll address for this one
yeah they nailed the spectacle and the
feeling of a Star Wars game but under
the surface I don't think there was too
much depth did you play much of the not
so much no I was really looking for a
single-player thing I mean I don't I
like some multiplayer games but I
usually focus on single player content
and I was you know not able to have that
so the single-player thing here have you
excited at all yeah totally cool I guess
that'll be definitely at the stage show
I think I believe we'll have we'll be
able to like cover it and play it pretty
positive next week be weird for them not
to let us uh but also need for speed
payback so like the Mel Gibson movie
yeah okay
Lethal Weapon 8 spin-off um well I
actually don't know much about this so
what did they announce around it what's
the story um I'm not even sure either I
just felt like it knows me for speed
payback they show this trailer and
everything i watch this they said it's
gonna basically need to speed the Fast
and Furious yeah against like a cartel
super story driven again yeah you're
playing three different characters in
the the storyline will switch between
those and you're gay or you're against a
cartel I think it's just called it's
called the house I believe and that's
the biggest thing I remember from this
trailer is at one point it sounds like
it drew cell burrs in it really or it's
someone who sounds a lot like is drew
sober means ham were having a long
discussion with her know it was maybe
some others to Troy elder I really hope
it's still
the really dumb first-person cutscenes
oh yes yeah oh yeah it was a robot
I forget the actor that was in it but it
was weird to see him in a game
especially in AP speed but I never
actually played the game I just saw the
trailers and those were enough to tell
me you have to play the game that's
exactly what I had with it and also
thing that stated some hints from Forza
horizon 3 laughter you got like off-road
stuff going alongside with with Street
stuff sure that game was great as well
so yeah there's anything like that sound
like a fictional Vegas right yeah like I
forgot to call it something City who
knows not Sin City but uh yeah moving on
from Need for Speed payback which will
also make an appearance at the press
conference we have uh Oscar I believe
you're a FIFA fan I am yeah yeah it's
like mandatory if you live in the UK uh
well I mean it's been a truly he's yes
he's working that rule thief eighteen do
we know what's gonna be newer there or
what I mean we know a bit they revealed
it on Monday I think so we know the
release a already I think September 29th
and the big news coming out of it was
that the switch version is not gonna be
is not on the same engine as think
there's four and three and Xbox one and
PC versions so there are those frostbite
yeah not as soon as they're Frost by now
and also it doesn't have the journey in
it which is sort of like FIFA's story
mode and that was sort of the big song
and dance that they had last year and
they're continuing it continuing it this
year but it's not going to be on switch
so it looks like this which is going to
be a really pared down version of FIFA
which is similar to what EA did with
FIFA on Vita in previous years and Wii U
as well which is a bit disappointing
hopefully it's still good but it doesn't
bode well where those previous versions
discounted I don't believe so no yeah
would you play it on the switch if it
was like the same specs if it is the
same spec yeah I mean I'd probably buy
both like I for the mobile aspect yeah
exactly
yeah unlike being able to like taking
control right and play like local co-op
FIFA on the go would be amazing but if
it's not going to be the top version of
it then kind of makes it a hard sell
doesn't it mm-hmm
did I mean I don't put a lot of FIFA but
I have to imagine if you're playing on
you know one half of the joy con you
know set up for two players the controls
have to be diminished
Greer acres p4 has desert-like slightly
complex controls I mean it's probably
it's complex the way I think of FIFA is
that is kind of like a fighting game is
that like for anyone who's not into that
genre is so like it's such a huge
barrier yeah
and now FIFA is actually quite good at
trying to lower that barrier to entry so
there's like alternate control schemes
and stuff like that so that like they
have a two button mode okay all right so
you could play it that way sure but I
mean I don't know a second second nature
to me narrow because I've played FIFA
for like right I don't know 15 years or
something but um like yeah it probably
wouldn't be the best on a single joi con
but what game is gonna be you know it's
just for the novelty of it I guess
sure who's your club crystal see I
represent ya likely Liverpool and I grew
up like in Liverpool and I used to watch
soccer just because I grew up in
Liverpool knew you grew up in Liverpool
New York or New York a key detail that
was omitted I was getting to it
yeah Madden 18 will also be out did I
hear there's a guy story mode with this
now - are they following the footsteps
of FIFA 17 believe so but you'll just
the room is that my rap football at
American football yeah cool I'm guy I
honestly haven't played Madden I
actually used to play Madden yearly up
until maybe 2009 or something but I
haven't seen too much of Madden in the
last few years I imagine they'll make a
few tweaks to keep people interested see
Tom burrow Tom Brady's on the cover if
everybody's worried about the curse you
guys heard of this that was the curse
it's just like every I forget how many
times that an athlete shows up in the
cover they get like seriously injured
it's more are than not it's like a weird
number percentage of time so there's
like oh my god why'd you put him on the
cover but I don't know it's I'm not too
superstitious but this Sims mobile it's
coming - they've been talking about
bringing that it's just obviously a pair
of down version for tablets phones you
guys like the Sims I am I don't buy the
Sims the way the normal people play The
Sims okay this is interesting like my
Sims usually lead the most miserable
lives possible oh gosh try and push them
to their limits
is that because you're negligent are you
trying to push them both - yeah I'm like
how I make their life worse so
can feel better about mine this is how
Dave beats me in the UK office but but
sim over there yeah I can't really do
that on the go because people look at my
phone and judge me yeah I'm making this
like random Sims live in trash when
you're making this digital hellscape
yeah
people on the tube won't look over and
give you weird looks I imagine that it's
got like quite a lot of
microtransactions as well like already
just on this you can see like coins coin
cash box and the previous Sims I had
that store when you could just buy one
piece of furniture and I think it was
Sims two or three that had like 40
expansion packs or some ridiculous like
an IKEA expansion and a hate jeanette
expansion it was literally uh like you
actually were shopping in a digital IKEA
yeah and buying these like very cookie
cutter desks I don't know um and then
another one that we know will be there
battlefield one in the name of the Czar
DLC um you know czar implying there
would be some sort of Russian front I
don't know whatever but I'm just one of
the bigger expansions I have you guys
played battlefield one much since it
released I played a bunch of battlefield
one on release I've not played it since
but I think this might actually get me
back into battlefield one okay
like if the like the cover the key R has
a woman on it so it looks like the doing
some really interesting things there in
world war one Russia actually had
something called the women's battalion
of death yeah most badass name for any
of ever heard yeah so if you can just
plain is like some badass ladies just
kicking kicking ass across the front
lines Russia I'll be sick yeah the young
weapons sweet new maps the campaign the
war stories that thought they did a
pretty good job they were kinda hit or
miss I didn't like the Italian one where
you're in that armor but I like the
Australian runner one and I also liked
you know kind of seeing things from
these different points of view uh the
Royal Air Force one was it the Royal Air
Force and World War one yeah they okay
um that doesn't think it was an Aussie
pilot in the in the war story gotcha
where does a Rasputin fall on the
timeline Elizabeth toward war
have no idea yeah but like if he's on
the front line should he be opiez
invincible a rescue running about yes
yes all these things but they kept
getting up
yes immortal in the game too that's
that's the newly class you just rescue
imploding sexy just staring at you those
eyes
cool so there you have it those the
games that we know will show up at ETA s
press conference for e3 and then we'll
also get to check those out and have
like hands-on demos and impressions for
you Battlefront to need for sweet
payback Madden 18 FIFA 18 Sims mobile
that'll feel won in the name of the Czar
DLC but I do want to talk about things
that are possible that could be their
aura get people's personal takes on what
you might want to see do you think we
will see anything about that like
Bioware IP that no one knows about the
new one that codename Dylan I think if
they are going to have something to show
that begin to show it especially after
mmm Mass Effect is a bit ropey try to
get back on there I got some favor back
yeah and it is the kind of formula
that's that's working for love RPG
Studios now yeah because the rumor is
it's called it's like codename Dylan
right now but people have been
speculating as to whether to try it
again to MMO style shooter space a lot
destiny yeah to be a tough competition
it'd be cool yeah be you have to come in
kind of swinging if you're gonna go to
tell it doesn't like it would Destiny's
problem his story right or least I was
my problem with the first testing it was
that I didn't didn't write the story at
all so if Bioware Bioware that's kind of
that speciality right so that could be a
really interesting take on it I'd like
to see them stick closer to the formula
of the division I think that's more
they'll be more Bioware style and
something to be able to work a little
bit super RPG ish third-person kind of
hoping world yeah that'd be interesting
to see over public do you guys play much
of that I played like the original night
so Republic G's I've never played the
MMO because I have a horrible addictive
personnel you wanna come I've heard good
things about it so I'd be interesting to
see how they could take that MMO style
and maybe Transplant it to like a new IP
you know we don't know it like buy
looted but what do you think the chances
of us seeing that this year are probably
pretty slim honestly I don't think
Bioware as a brand that needs to be
paraded around right now
yeah frankly you don't think like this
could help them get back on track well I
mean they're different studios under the
buyer one name but I think it they're
just you know they might need a little
breathing room
yeah sit this one out maybe and you know
III is the place for everyone draws
comparisons or what makes grand
conclusions based on very little
information and right now that brand
kind of carries you know sort of a
negative tone mm-hmm yeah yeah it's just
my hunch I'd be curious as hell to see
it yeah I wouldn't be surprised if it
didn't show up yeah because you can see
someone else try to cuz the division was
kind of I feel like Ubisoft attempt to
get into that destiny space
I just because laying on a Bungie I feel
like got their toe in the door before a
lot of other people and we know destiny
too is coming on September 8th if I'm
not mistaken but it would be interesting
to see what bio I could do but in terms
of Star Wars releases dice is not the
only one working on battle Star Wars
there's battlefront too but we know
visceral and respawn are both working on
some sort of Star Wars projects you
think we'll see like teasers or any
mention of these kind of things Amy
Hennig is working with this role on I
think that one will see something you
think I don't think we'll see anything
no because I think cuz that's just
eating into Battlefront right that's
just fun I'm in the opposite view I
think they'll get them they'll get
really hyped for Star Wars and they'll
tease something else Star Wars is just
building that rollercoaster Episode
eight coming out December yeah it's kind
of a leading up to one of those years
you're not like last year was the off
year with a rogue
what was that bounty hunter game that
was what I'm sorry wait what was the one
behind you one rogue wanna thank you I
knew there's no missing broke eight
someone help me
what were you saying the Bounty Hunter
game that was kind of shelved Oh
thirteen thirteen yeah that it's like
that was given a new injection of life
that were always wandering people or I
was wondering if that was what became a
me headaches project I thought maybe I
think did they not say that it was like
completely like that project is push the
backburner clean cancelled yeah I
thought so yeah yeah I'm more interested
in that curiously what respawn will be
doing I like next action game
I love respawn just based on the two
games they've made which are titanfall
games but don't I'm full too
yes thank you that's a couple numbers
yeah
uh yeah I think we could see the Amy
Hennig one definitely I don't think
respawn would show anything off right
now no I mean I think you've just a
couple months ago they said that they're
working quietly on the game yeah nothing
I mean that says they're in the planning
phase they're not going to have anything
concrete to show and there's still like
pumping out titanfall to content not
that they can't something it yep just
like throwing it at us not that they
can't work on that simultaneously but
I'd be interested to see what they're
working on but I don't think we will see
it this year at EA their press
conference anything else you guys hope
to see that I didn't mention FIFA 19
just gonna jump the gun show us FIFA 20
as well yeah yeah we can see what kind
of features they're adding in a few
years and just play 18 anyway ea the
rugby game yeah I play that that'd be
the one sports game I play do you like
rugby like I'm not manically Welsh you
would uh you're from Wales
so my blood boil uh what are some some
Welsh terms you can throw me right now -
boyo and run em run that well tidy gag
is no tidy gag Qaeda gag it sounds
sexual and shut your mouth oh my god
okay cool well anyway anything else you
want dad
no yeah that's I just like that that's
useful Qaeda gag is that a good kind of
gag dude all right cool dude I am i
Americanized it yeah it good [ __ ] me um
cool so that's ei their press conference
is Saturday yeah you betcha
and I believe the lobby crew you Cali
Rob Handler and I we will be doing the
pre and post shows for that so come back
to GameSpot I believe it's around noon
12:30 Pacific time Saturday from Los
Angeles you can come check that out on
GameSpot - which YouTube will be there
covering it for you all right let's move
on another publisher one that I like a
lot of the property so I'm excited for
this Bethesda seems like we know quite
champions gonna be there yeah that's the
one they've been like saying we're
definitely have I would I know John Luke
played a little bit of the beta alpha
that they just released recently it was
a beta at this point closed beta you
guys decided for that you like an
old-school shooter fan
no no no oh yeah because you would mourn
when old schools you is were thing yeah
you're born when old school she's 21
ready old school she is they were
already cool the old school by that
point Goldeneye was a nautical shooter
when you're born yeah you're 21
yeah okay so Dave what about quake are
you excited like champions yeah I am I
played
the beta the vibe I got was that they
were taking you there they were testing
the formula with do multiplayer yeah
they want they were trying to get that
fluidity and like twitch shooting and
then they were like okay this works but
we need two packages quake yeah and it's
a lot of fun
the only thing that I'm kind of iffy
about is again the whole
microtransaction thing like buying and
renting new Harris I absolutely can rent
here oh I hate the renting system in in
multiplayer games that you can like rent
guns and rent heroes and yuccas you can
give I think there's like silver or gold
and just have it like a day or a few
hours I just hate that system well the
the champions aspect comes in their
actual like classes or isn't that yeah
there's there's very small differences
like the one you get is thing is just
like the grunt other soldier he can
teleport and there's one that's not like
a hoverboard that can move quite fluidly
and do specific moves they're all the
knives and the of the argument they're
all the same they have very small
different abilities that may just come
in when it comes to like high level play
yeah but like like that as you saw we
just teleported and he's on his
hoverboard she can think cloak again
they're very subtle things it's really
just about gain quad damage and and
rocket launches and going nuts yeah it's
weird I mean we're gonna get to the
rumors about a Wolfenstein 2 later but
looking at Wolfenstein the new order and
the new doom from last year seems like I
mean obviously it's down the creator's
like it's software that makes games and
uh machine games they made Wolfenstein
yeah correct yeah um it seems like all
these older shooters have had really
successful well made reboots yeah
and I'm curious if quake champions will
kind of continue that tradition quite
being very different more multiplayer
focus from at least when I used to play
it but I'm curious to see how that plays
out I know a John Luke had like pretty
positive impressions from playing it cuz
it feels good obviously much faster than
games a game I enjoyed it yeah it was it
was just like the kind of overarching
microtransactions stuff that just yeah
it's me a little bit but I mean mostly
it was a good time yeah to another
shooter that is mentioned Wolfenstein to
rumors Brian bloom the voice actor for
BJ blaskowitz and also the
actor from call duty infinite warfare he
actually works Infinity Ward as a writer
now but he had been saying so at the new
order announcement a couple years ago
they had that das screen that came up at
the beginning of Bethesda's conference
yeah and it said like a few different
code names one was like new order one
was doom and they kind of hinted it a
few things and then there's one they
said like the new Colossus yeah people
are suspecting heavily that that is
Wolfenstein - and it's been Wolfenstein
new order was 2014 if I'm not mistaken
seems like it's time to bring that out
because it did really well and it was
you know absolutely yeah I was really
good I actually replayed a look at the
other night because I hadn't played in a
while but they then they released the
old blood that pretty lengthy about
six-hour campaign you know addition to
it and people are thinking that that's
what they're gonna announce this year
because and maybe new Colossus is either
the actual name for the sequel or just
like a working working title kind of
progress name I think it actually might
be the name yeah there's a few so the
new Colossus is actually a poem about
the Statue of Liberty mm-hmm which makes
me think maybe they'll continue the
german-occupied thing and go actually
stuff battling to get America back yeah
and it's all the Colossus is also a
world war two code breaking machine so
we can maybe do something like that in
Bletchley Park so it could even go back
to the UK oh cool so there's there's a
few like subtle connections to world war
ii history that they could maybe draw on
yeah I'd like to see them maybe take it
like Eastwood yet the Russian army or
something and kind of give it an extra
little spin on the Wolfenstein formula
take away from the German inspiration
yeah did I ask her do you play new order
I didn't I know it was one I always
wanted to get round to playing cuz it
looked really interesting and I don't
know it was an old game made modern
which I'm into yeah cuz all games are
rubbish
yeah the wrong person you want Jew riots
Sony man haha oh yeah there's neither
sales exact that said no one wants
backwards ain't it who would play these
yeah no he said everyone wants these
game everyone wants backwards
compatibility no one uses it and besides
look at these games who would want to
play this yeah well you have opinions
about that clearly but what do you think
of that about what
what he said ill informed well
nah it rubs me the wrong way because at
one hand he's acknowledged and yeah a
lot of people want this then he's
basically dismissing their opinions for
his own as someone who doesn't care
about those things and that's that's
it's just kind of rude to the people
that are telling him hey we want this
yeah his one thing if he was like yeah
no one uses backwards-compatibility
and left it at that you know or said
it's just not worth it from a business
perspective cool but to disparage these
games and say that they're basically
worthless is not true and not fair yeah
Wolfenstein new order is still worth
playing if you want to get prepped for a
possible sequel that might be announced
if it says this conference I just play
the other night still holds up very well
yeah which I would hope it does because
it's three years old but yeah you should
go check it out yeah it's pretty brutal
too but yeah it's very it's very
old-school and the weapon dial you know
like a like retching Clank or something
but you don't have like the dual weapon
call duty system you can also you know
there's health and armor it's not just
the recharging health
I did get find myself getting stuck when
where to go a few times more than I
remembered but I think that just might
because you know linear shooters have
conditioned me to be used to that but
push your rubbish your games yeah
exactly I suck
just Russell coming from two planned all
this old blood is also good I think it
was a little more stealth focused which
I like it played more on the aspects of
Evan Stein as well yeah so go play that
if you haven't it's really good
and then another sequel from Bethesda
tango GameWorks evil within two could be
there possibly there were those rumors
uh psycho break is the name of evil
within in Japan hmm there was a job
listing for psycho break two semi
recently translators I think yeah it's
late a QA lead I think it was sure yeah
and something's happening for that yeah
for those who don't know Shinji Mikami
the evil Odin was his new IP that he
brought out 2014 creator of Resident
Evil and principle behind vanquish and
vanquish yes which also just got a PC
release that's your sweet ass at death
which apparently is very good but yeah
and Bethesda and tango both have said
that they wanted to make evil within a
franchise you know like because uh you
know you have resin evil now coming out
resonable seven the not a hero DLC might
be at e3 but
that's all Shinji Mikami's not involved
other than people anymore
from what I understand maybe overseeing
things oh really
yeah well I mean I don't think it's not
like he's severed ties I don't think but
I don't he didn't have too much say over
a resonable seven that was mainly like
oh I'm sorry I thought you're telling
people within
oh no sorry yeah present yeah but yeah
evil within I really liked there was
fifteen chapters
I loved the first ten I hate the last
five I thought that had serious patient
pacing issues toward the end but
honestly I think that game was at its
best when it was like Resident Evil
president for at least when they had
like you know they give you this village
and you're running around and kind of
using all the tools your disposal to
survive I really like I believe his name
Salvatore Castellanos something like
that I didn't really like him he's
clearly forgettable with none of us know
who he is
um I feel his name well what you butches
isn't he doesn't saying yeah I might
have never got it correctly this key
like the first game a lot of like not
even like the right kind of inventory
management like you could collect like a
lot of things in the environment have a
lot of useful junk does that sound right
I don't remember I played the whole
thing too but it was kind of played
straight through fast but junk see look
at yeah Sebastian Castellanos I said
Salvatore
woops sorry I was close but yeah so even
within - it's likely that it might show
up we don't have it confirmed but based
on that job listing and the fact that it
kind of seems like Wolfenstein it might
be the right time bringing out we might
see that at Bethesda quake champions
definitely come out I want to talk about
possible things that are likely or we
kind of hope
dishonor - DLC you guys I think that's
good yeah right it's I mean they brought
the witches of brigmore if I'm not
mistaken for the first game that's part
of the deluxe edition that was a pretty
lengthy DLC with prey out and with the
the Leone studio from arcane over in
France like Dishonored 2 came out last
year did really well critically I don't
think it's sold as well as the first
game but it seems like the time to bring
out DLC right and uh yeah it seems like
why wouldn't they if they did the same
thing for the first one the second one
you know for all intents purposes I
liked it was better in my opinion but
you guys think this will be there yeah
almost almost definitely I'd like to see
them do something similar to a the knife
of dunwall where again you got to kind
of see something from a different angle
then as all
also more cities in the dead world
soccer now but yeah rink arnica they
could go back to dunwall but then
there's like way north which is all snow
instead save something that for a third
game but seeing something from maybe the
the lady that was piloting the ship I
remember her faster yes seeing something
for maybe her point of view and
exploring her pan because she was quite
an interesting character that could be
quite cool yeah they really they
revealed these they kind of trickled
these little like tidbits about her that
maybe I want to learn more throughout
dishonor to so that'd be fairly pretty
cool yeah it seems like I feel like
Harvey Smith is gonna come on stage and
just talk about this because uh you know
I'm sure Arcana arcane Austin's already
working on prey DLC maybe we'll see that
down the road but yeah seems likely with
prey coming out that with prey out there
to separate studios and right but you
know it seems like this will be the time
to announce it absolutely um
dooms story DLC do you think we'll see
that or is that just like something the
public just really wants I really want
it yeah I think everyone wants it but I
feel like that should as sale yeah soon
was a while ago and I yeah yeah last
year cuz I mean they brought out like
multiplayer stuff but I didn't play
multiplayer in that game I just liked it
for single-player you know the other
thing that Pete Hines mentioned when he
I think did that quote that you
referenced earlier regarding like they
want they're wanting to make think I'm
an evil with evil than a franchise yeah
like in the same breath he we talked
about rage uh sold well enough to be you
know to fall into that category really
oh damn yeah that was part of that
little discussion he had so maybe
instead of new dune they're working on
something rage related we I mean doom is
obviously the more popular one but it's
like it's too late for the LC but really
for sequels precisely yeah so rage might
fill that gap but you know the first
rage was huge undertakings so that's
also a long shot yeah wolves rage 2012
11 uh maybe even a year to earlier than
that yeah yeah I wasn't a fan know radii
Rangers like 2009 really damn yeah I'm
getting I think yeah so maybe no doom
this year at all Elder Scrolls online
content you see let's think you'll see
that with the morrowind stuff coming out
like right now they'll probably show it
yeah but it's already out right so
there's not pretty money yeah if they
might touch on it but like you saying
because marwan's now out and they might
just be
they might just want to address the else
cause online fans be like there is more
stuff coming this is like the end of it
so they're parked there I just outline
like the content plan for the next year
or so I don't think we'll see anything
massive for them no they put that card
game to you know they're gonna pimp that
yeah but if those girls legend legends
it yeah they might have something that
like tie those two get together I am
surprised they've not tried that already
sure yeah with Gwent doing so well and
obviously the hearthstone craze coming
back after a couple years they've been
supporting that throughout the years
alright longshots Elder Scrolls six no
yeah it's a pipe dream I mean I want it
to happen if if anything they will talk
about it like two minutes and just hint
that they might work on something chug
the amount of time since Skyrim sairam's
announcement it feels like the right
time feels like the right time but the
worry is that because they're pushing
Elder Scrolls online really hard
especially with morrowind having just
come out there is the worry that that
would they would compete with each other
so well Skyrim special edition came out
last year too as well as drew is it on
the switch yet or to come and switch
this year and switch yeah so here's what
I think there were all those like kind
of like people were sifting through
files and finding references to project
Louisiana from obsidian right you're
looking back obsidian did Fallout New
Vegas absolutely on a great studio and
then summary yeah there are a lot of
references to New Orleans in Fallout 4
so I'm wondering if maybe they'll
announce like a spin-off kind of like a
la New Vegas that obsidian is gonna work
on well Bethesda folks is elsewhere I've
been wanting obsidians next fall out
since fallout 4 Fallout New Vegas is my
favorite fallout of all time and like
just the just the flavor obsidian give
to it like it's a little more eclectic
it has a little bit more character and
as much as I did enjoy fallout 4 I think
it did miss the mark a little bit so I
want to go back into the fallout world
and have the same level of enjoyment as
I had in in new vegas and it feels like
New Orleans is a perfect setting for a
Fallout game like New Vegas works so
well because there was the whole new
Vegas aesthetic there's gambling there
was there's everything that made Vegas
Vegas and New Orleans is obviously an
area where stuff is sober salted to it
yeah that would be perfect for a fallout
game yeah a new
in gays in crocodiles yeah one cool
thing about New Vegas that a lot of it
was untouched by the the nuclear
apocalypse because it wasn't it's not
this like huge bustling Washington DC
New York Justin's thriving city center
but I don't know you played a lot of
Fallout 4 PN are you interested in
something like that from obsidian uh
I almost want to shift gears and talk
about something that's rumored go for it
starlight I think it's called is it
what's that it always at the the sci-fi
elder scrolls so that supposed to be the
game that falls between Fallout which is
the first of the third acts in the world
and then starlight and then Elder
Scrolls being said the far future whoops
Elder Scrolls set in the far future that
was what I read like a post post
apocalypse like horizon yeah really yeah
so like shared universe stuff yeah are
like it's like an official thing but
that is sort of like the working theory
if I remember correctly yeah where were
these rumors come from do you remember
uh I think it was head yeah yeah this
guy in the street yes yes sir for a
dollar and I gave to me was going to
tell you something this homeless guy
asked me for a serum told me all about
it no but it's game starlight I mean
like I think I would I would like to see
something other than you know weird high
fantasy [ __ ] and and the fallout post
apocalypse stuff I'm a little burnt down
on it if I'm honest you want some like
sci-fi kind of cleanse your palate yeah
I mean there's a lot of sci-fi out there
but not really sci-fi in the same vein
that we're talking yeah what was the
game that came out last year that was
kind of going for that Elder Scrolls in
space
uh something projects soulless us so I
miss a solaris but so I think you're
right soulless something soulless yeah
they were kind of going for that a
sandbox sci-fi thing yeah obviously they
without the resources and talent of
Bethesda they might not ever
accomplished it right cool so yeah
that's anything else you were mentioned
from Bethesda before I kick you guys out
of here they're probably gonna do a
bunch of VR stuff if I had to guess
yeah because at Gamescom at e3 last year
there was a booth showing fallout for VR
raising a baby back at e3 last year yeah
I've been III so that Todd Howard talks
about it every chance he gets but I
guess that's just a sell like I'm I
fallout for VR all I remember from
people who actually played it was that
made me real sick yeah I would yeah I've
actually come
think I'd be very surprised they didn't
show follow 4vr this has happened before
the right because alien isolation was
showing off in VR loads when that was
coming out and they're just now they
just never released it yeah
which it seems a bizarre decision but if
yours pretty cold right now there's not
a lot of hype around it we've had the
product launches we've had some good
games but you know there's really
nothing to get really excited about and
I don't know that porting a smaller
version of an existing game as a couple
years old is that I don't know if that
can fix that problem
mmm cool that's Bethesda uh their
conference is that what 8:00 p.m.
Pacific on Sunday it's gonna be fun what
is that I don't know maybe you and I are
covering that are you doing that with us
uh-oh to the event itself the pre and
post shows yeah oh yeah I'll be on this
stage okay close three don't be a late
night talking about Bethesda games
anyway on the east coast or the UK you
can wake up to some news that'll be fun
I still have they given an explanation
for that timing I think it's just it's
best for the international audience
except the UK yeah everyone good guys
all right well yeah everybody joining
that was our EA Bethesda predictions and
hopes Dave Jewett Oscar dais thanks so
much for coming on thanks - we will
you'll be seen these - a lot on stage
throughout the coming week at e3 but
right now I'm gonna kick you off all
right well see ya what was that what's
the shut up in Welsh Qaeda gag guy - get
out of here dude alright we are going to
bring on our Australia crew or at least
a couple of them Ed Tran and Eddie makuu
he's gone the wrong way
yeah there you go ah sweet sure you know
both of these fine people from Australia
from again GameSpot News you've been
doing the news updates out of our office
here this week haven't you how's that
been going
it's different because we're shooting in
the afternoon now we usually shoot 6:00
in the morning
oh yeah it's a lively really good we're
having some sleep except the jetlag
mm-hmm that's something else is Jess
MacDonald yeah Dan crowd okay thank you
for having us yeah you guys still jam I
say good night I feel like we should
take it out today you know good day is
that no the audience no you don't said
good you get rid of the or g'day there
you go there you go day very good good
man cool well I want to bring you on for
a couple side
but first off how is how's your trip so
far to San Frisco you both been you're
right no it's my first first time
have you been to America before I have I
have but never San Fran yeah it's very
nice very nice
yeah your temperature is like perfect
yeah I can wear a jacket at all times
sorry like it's always the same
temperature today yes which is sometimes
it's kind of nerve-wracking like when
you live here for extended period of
time but yeah it's cold in winter it
doesn't does it no it's not really a
death there's no season oh I think the
warmest month is like September
oddly enough yeah it's a better October
it'll get like get on yeah yeah we
covered the weather yeah coming up on
sports tonight just a bunch of awkward
strangers that happen to be on set
together
Edmund Tran for those you know is what
having a kid soon he getting ready he
himself is having a kid yes so it's very
strange it's a mall of Australia is
waiting in anticipation for me
personally I had to pump out a child
yeah that's right yeah so he couldn't
make it to e3 for obvious reasons Eddie
makuu who actually used to be on the
American East Coast as her news editor
is in the Australia office now he's here
but he's pretty busy with ei stuff
incidentally just prepping for III press
conference and whatnot but want to bring
you two on get you guys on for Ubisoft
go yeah Nintendo nice so we'll start
with Ubisoft ok I'm we've been just
talking about what we're definitely to
see what we will likely see and maybe if
you have any like crazy dreams seeing uh
some of these leaks recently Assassin's
Creed origins there's that big leak
apparently it's going to be like a
reboot of the series uh when a Ubisoft
announced far cry 5 and the new crew
game they also had that Assassin's Creed
kind of teaser yeah it was just an image
or was a video I think was just an image
right yeah yeah logo logo yeah yeah we
got that very out-of-focus image yeah
our first look and then the t-shirt no
that's my favorite way that a leak has
ever happened wait what was wait what
was the story manatee it was like the
protagonist came up on like a
permutation and it was a picture of you
know what's supposedly than you
assassins protagonist for origins and
his name is by yech according to the
t-shirt and it's got hieroglyphics oh
yeah that seems to lend credence to the
Egypt theory whew
and this would set it earliest in the
Assassin's Creed timeline so far and
it's also kind of are you guys excited
because they took a year off because for
a while yeah actually yeah I'm always
happy when publishers or devs decide to
take a step back and focus on quality
like I'm happy with that I don't need
the annualize franchise I love when they
bring out stuff that I can play every
year but if they're doing it for a
reason to just make a better game I will
always take a better game yeah this is
the image that John Luke just pulled up
and see the marker here and everything
and they said apparently from the leaks
it's gonna be like exponentially bigger
than Black Flag which is pretty much
really open-world pirate world man yeah
about this bigger bigger business
because there's been so many big games
and I just I'm running out of time
there's enough time in my day I like
Mass Effect so big
Zelda oh my god yeah come on come on
yeah like I don't know I don't know if I
got it very different like interesting
stories of the fact that bigger can be
better or bigger can be just bigger yeah
sorry we could go either way mmm true
true yeah well you guys did a video or
you just you did a video about Mass
Effect yeah right yeah and that's really
my conclusion it was just like you know
there the whole thing was oh the world's
gonna be so much bigger like just one of
our story planets is gonna be the size
of Inquisition and I was like holy crap
I put a hundred hours into Inquisition
like are you sure you have enough good
stuff to pack in there and I think
personally they didn't but yeah it will
be interested to see what comes of
Assassin's Creed I'm excited if it's an
Egypt setting I think yeah I think a lot
of us have been waiting for Assassin's
Creed to go to Egypt for a really long
time so that would be really cool yeah
is ever since the ending of the first
game right where you see those markings
on the wall that kind of alluded to a
few different spots there's like Incan
ruins symbols everything but the
hieroglyphics were the one that stood
out and I think everybody always wanted
to be a ninja in that series
Ubisoft continually said no we're not
gonna do yeah now you're basically a
ninja though I know yeah pretty much
so uh I'm kind of safest I didn't play
syndicate at all yeah me neither
I don't get into syndicate I really
wanted to do it was I loved Black Flag
but not because there's an assassin's
Creed games because I thought as a cool
pirate it'll
just made fun of assassin's creed the
entire time yeah it was so good which I
was in the mood for that SAS entreat
three kind of soured me I was really
looking forward to it being an American
Revolution but I didn't like the game
but they introduced a naval come about
that yeah its way into Sanskrit for in a
big way
um far cry 5 we know much more about
that they released that uh the Last
Supper cover we talked about that in the
lobby a few times the fact that it's set
in Montana yeah kind of like radical
Christian cultists that take over this
hope county yep are you guys excited for
that I am I'm definitely excited I love
Parker I yeah and I like that they
always seem to have they're going for
the interesting villain and this villain
looks super super interesting even
though we haven't seen much of him
except for his man bond so that's pretty
exciting that's pretty much that's the
but yeah I mean I had a man bun and that
was when I did all of my evil things in
here yeah yeah yeah and then I thank God
um but also I just want to I make my
wallets you know all that kind of stuff
is what is love I remember saying this
when primal came out because primal was
such a huge change of pace for fog right
but what I loved and sort of hey this is
going to sound very cynical about fall
cries how they managed to take a
completely different setting and make
the exact same game yeah there's always
a spark right elements it's very
reliable like you definitely know what
you're getting um so I'd be really
interested if they step away from that
formula at all but you know even if it
is just a setting change its setting
that I'm interested in so yeah yeah and
I think as Kelly brought up it's a it's
got the potential to get a little
controversial I wonder how they're gonna
handle that
yeah whether they use it to their
advantage to tell an interesting story
yeah with you know like possible
commentary or if they just royally screw
it up yeah what do you think about a
setting I'm excited for it I like the
idea that you know like three and four
both were especially three or literally
like this frat dude mmm um and she's you
know people going into a foreign land
and kind of [ __ ] it up and getting
into their problems it's nice to see it
come here after like I believe far cry 4
you were also American if I'm not
mistaken it would be nice to see it come
to this soil I don't know uh
are you excited for this no i yuri
talked about yeah I met odds with the
setting I'm at odds of frankly my
country so
yeah you know I don't I think about this
crap far too often so yeah I don't need
to play in the video yeah but what if
this becomes like a good outlet for that
internal rage I don't have I don't need
that kind of that way move away from
aside for a little bit um well speaking
of far cry 5 and Assassin's Creed coming
back I want to talk about a kind of
property that seems to have a little
space open do you think we'll see a
Splinter Cell at all
oh man cuz the Ghost Recon just came out
I would hope so vision was new um how
long ago last one was conviction oh yeah
when was that 14 no I was it was before
no blacklist was last one black horse
easy dick she was like she doesn't know
like this was when they recast and
Fischer and it's like young Sam Fisher
and uh Michael Ironside is rumored to be
coming back or something for another one
in the future or maybe it's like a
hopeful thing but um yeah it seems like
this might be the time to do it they
brought out the division as a new IP two
years ago yeah
Ghost Recon just launched this year
Rainbow six was two years about the end
of your rainbow six have been doing
really well yeah like it's numbers
doubled since it released as of a few
months ago that's great good yeah it's
really good um and splinter cell's the
one existing Tom Clancy franchise unless
you want to talk about n war oh I'm not
gonna bring that back my daughter
oh man hawks that's right yeah I doubt
they're gonna bring either of those back
so now you have Splinter Cell I liked
blacklist but a lot of people didn't
like that they took kind of uh like
those branching you get to go there's
three kind of missions one was like
stealthy couldn't be noticed but you
know there was like a salt but I really
like the conviction actually but my
favorite is like a lot of people as
chaos theory yeah I think that game is
close as close to perfect as a stealth
game has been yet um but I would be
really excited to see Sam Fisher come
back this year and I wonder if we will
see that maybe maybe I mean that's the
thing about e3 you like I feel like you
just have no idea what's gonna happen
sometimes and that's what's so exciting
it'd be awesome to see more Sam Fisher I
think I love stealth games Metal Gear
Solid 5 yeah favorite games oh yeah it
was like it the perfect game play so
yeah yeah um the crew - you guys like
the first crew um I wasn't a huge fan of
it felt like all that open space there
was just not like the idea of it
yeah like Savior like II don't know I
got into an argument about this before I
left Australia and I said it wasn't very
good because it was so open and he said
it was very good because it was like he
could put on some dad rock and just like
drive across America and I was like I
want like the Forza horizon 3 version
and right yeah you guys got it oh and
like that is so good it's a perfect
representation of Australia so maybe if
there's a crew to do what for - did and
just downside is it in - it all together
yeah um but I don't know you reckon they
do like America again or would they just
do somewhere else not know what hope
none of it yeah I cry fives got that
covered
yeah maybe better soon in there yeah
Europe or somewhere I don't know yeah
yup ancient Egypt oh yeah that would be
yes yeah yeah yeah yeah sick uh yeah cuz
Forza horizon 3 definitely when it
played that uh because you can meet how
old you guys probably obviously would
know this more than I would but how
geographically accurate was it uh in one
would not yeah absolutely was like
watchdogs to was set in San Francisco
and it was very much like kind of a
microcar they did a great job
but even then kind of to a straight yeah
well as is like literally like states
agenda up in completely different ways
is they just they took the highlights of
the country and yeah like the outback
isn't a place like there's no way cold
Viper really it's just like the middle
they have guys call Natalie have you
ready here they have some important new
sea stakes that out back ah very good is
that you get a fat right sweep like well
done man
well done well done I know the thing
about salsa was the best thing they did
was the really small details like the
telephone poles in Australia are green
they're like treated pine and they're
all green that was perfect we have like
hexagonal light poles that was right now
we're Texas we have hexagonal poles as
well the top sides no oh wait those be
asking aren't that Suns I know good one
shut up my man of the world
I merely I've been to Australia very
nice you should come down sometime I
want to motorboat sir yeah get that like
represents it enough yeah just I could
say I've been there yeah um what about
South Park the fractured but whole that
would be there yeah I love
mispronouncing I'm not gonna go with
there but have you guys done the flat
mosque the camo no I've heard of this so
I've done it yeah and it is describe
what I say um yeah anyone who doesn't
know it was like this promo ah mask that
when you fight in game it like shoots
fart smell up your nose and down your
throat and you're so he almost ruined it
was still lingering inside oh man like
it wasn't just the smell it was like the
pressure that's forced like there it was
it was it was a real experience of mine
but real grace I'm really excited for it
I loved the first one I could yeah me
too
really came for the fact that they
seemed very determined to improve on it
as well like I thought the first game
was really solid but they're like no
we're gonna make the gameplay better
we're gonna make the combat better I
mean it was there's you go there's no
more there's your pop mom making a cameo
before he comes on oh there's Lucy there
that that is perfect white yeah knows
ulis rift yeah coming yeah yeah and uh
I'm really interested in this game
because I did play like the first half
of the first one finally earlier this
year I took me a while to get to it but
I believe from what I've heard that
they're going more of longer like a
tactical yeah like um kind of yeah yeah
so man like which is your red and like
if you get behind enemies you get like
boosts and stuff like that which is
pretty cool yeah um and the first game
was really substantial I mean for a game
based on you know a TV show there's this
relatively low expectations but that
game was huge I don't blame you for only
playing half of it cuz yeah long as [ __ ]
yeah and I love South Park and it felt
very much like a huge South Park like a
season of salwar yeah it definitely does
and the town was great and a little
references with great wood that was a
very good time that first game I can't
wait for the second one like the side
quest structured around those incidental
characters from the show yeah awesome
and I'm looking forward to this because
this gameplay actually looks more fun to
me yeah yeah it's a civil war it's like
an actual sequel it's like you play as
the same characters that's pretty cool
yeah that is cool yeah I'm looking
forward to it because that was
originally supposed to be last December
then got
push back it's gotten pushed by a few
yeah yeah um just like the first game I
got push back so many times
yeah well cuz our Trey Parker and Matt
Stone directly involved this one as well
yeah I like they were the first okay
cool um and then uh there are a few
other ones I wanted to add steep Rayman
legends the definitive edition and Just
Dance are likely to come to switch
they'll put too much recognition on that
at the press conference
I'm sure they'll show off justice
doesn't coughing the first 10-15 minutes
I'll be shocked what's silly as you can
play just dance with your phone you can
play just literally with every without
any electronically play it right now
yeah play just dance with my doing and
it almost went straight into the TV yeah
all you have to hold it yeah you have to
hold your phone yeah I mean I have to
hold it but then you'll drop it yeah
okay
interesting um that said the joy cones
are a good idea for Justin yeah cuz I
just light little but for rayman legend
the definitive edition that would be
awesome to have on switch doing you know
what's the different of that game like
what happens there to add serious wasn't
it all there at the start like prima is
it just playing on the bus now yeah you
gonna leave it up where's one of the
lunch skis and in this yeah and it is
like Raymond adventure on iPhone which
is like the same it's a minor it's an
easy win right the game is done they can
just poured it they can call whatever
they want it's also fantastic yeah it's
not to disparage the game but it's
totally been around for years
yeah I'm speaking of Rayman legends
while Michelle and sell started Rayman
about Beyond Good and Evil 2 damn it
Magellan sell you're killing me what we
do it every year
honey I've worked at GameSpot I'm a
confession I don't really like Beyond
Good and Evil
what yeah get out please dollar to you
am I the only one here I didn't finish
it I play a little bit it was fine
I don't I don't get the same infatuation
I didn't like in like how like item
Goethe it was what were you collecting
those orbs or whatever there yes yeah I
want to say spirit always just not what
the cold that's Jackie Dexter I think
not jackal demos are those there's a
pretty close the whole game and you also
take pictures of all the animals in the
game you can take pictures of to get
credits like Pokemon snap it's like jak
and daxters like Metroid oh man it's
never gotten sky Oh
maybe I played it like after it's time
I'm like sure - I played it when I was
very young and like female protagonist I
was like yay great um and then you know
we played it when I was older and I
quite enjoy it it's a little bit janky
in the gameplay Department to replay now
yeah which is again why would we really
awesome if they bring out a second one
so what did you want from a sequel I
think that's maybe the biggest question
because that teaser they showed what six
years ago was was just so boring yeah so
there was also that leaked gameplay of
Jade running around running away from
something
they got leaks a few years ago as well
yeah she's running away from the sequel
hey confirmed to be beyond Guerneville
she gameplay um but they don't really
want to confirm anything but I think as
far as the gameplay goes I think they've
got a good foundation for what it
originally was I mean you know say Miss
South Park like it would be awesome to
see them iterate on that and make it
even better like take it a step above
the story was really good it had this
like really fascinating story of like
rising up against the man and then like
the more that cuz you're basically an
investigative journalist like taking
down this like evil government
conglomerate and the people don't know
that they're evil and then the more that
you expose what's going on you see the
town change and like the people start
rising up and I love that stuff I don't
think you get those things a lot that
sounds cool maybe I just think it far
enough into it yeah yeah and I also just
recently quite agree sorry
it's yeah yeah I'm like jak and daxter
one which is one of my favorite games I
played that again recently and I was
like blend analyze and so it's a little
bit janky yeah
whereas Beyond Good and Evil I feel like
it still plays quite well it's
impossible to get to run on pc though oh
my god took me forever
oh you're playing it on one leg through
Steam yeah I think it was through Steam
yet but it's been good I use all these
patches and it's just why would anyone
play on PC it's too hot God that said
we've been told by not seeing it at e3
but we'll see it this year which I bet
means concept art yeah my expectations
are low yeah um and then one more that
Mario + Mario Rabbids Kingdom battle
that's been long rumored do we know
anything about that or is it just that
with it showed like that meant a shot or
something yeah it looks like a menu
screen but what is this um my money is
on it's gonna be announced at Ubisoft
press conference not at Nintendo's yeah
I think yeah
but I apparently according to the same
person who liked the image said that
it's going to be a turn-based RPG right
yes and I that sounds so interest I'll
be appealing right yeah why I just think
of Super Mario RPG which I really like
yeah like I don't know I mean it's also
like why would you use the Rabbids when
Raymond is already like a really perfect
platform because minions dan right well
I know yeah I don't know I'm intrigued
by it I think I'll give it a look in
just because I'm like what the hell
could it be and Rabbids aren't that
annoying to me yet no sorry not minion
level annoying not me you're not
annoying no I have to alright so that is
Ubisoft that is what we expect to see
and what we hope to see let's move on we
just kind of touched on it Nintendo oh
boy yeah what overlap hey guys you guys
excited for this oh man I can't wait
yeah yeah I need something to play on my
switch sir yeah I mean a lot of games on
switch yeah I know um I think I think
that we're just gonna see a bunch of
way.you ports to be honest yes I think
they're like we brought out so many good
games Wii U and such a small amount of
like our market played them like you
look at the numbers of people who picked
up the way and then the people who
picked up we year like they lost so much
of their fanbase and they seem to be
getting it back this which seems to be
somewhat successful and we're already
seeing ports come across right pocket so
I think poking poking okay so we're
probably gonna see more of those yeah I
think you're onto something I think
we'll probably see hints of like zelda
HD stuff being imported over my big
guess is that we're going to see the DLC
for breath of the wild drop at the show
yeah is there precedent for that like
that's what a lot of people are saying
right well Nintendo always idiy through
that they release something like last
year it was Rhythm Heaven right yes but
they've said look this is coming out
during the summer and if they drop it at
a time when we're all busy covering
every other you know convention company
they also run their treehouse live thing
this perfect opportunity for them to
continue the conversation and be sort of
the one controlling that message because
debt that's all they're gonna be able
it's gonna be that and Mario Odyssey
mm-hmm I think I'm gonna dominate the
show for them yeah definitely yeah I
want to get back to Mario Odyssey but
crimson Dragoon 23 and the twist Jets
fingers crossed for Xenoblade - you like
zeolite a lot do you think - over here
it mean it's supposed to come out this
year yeah yeah I mean like do you think
they'll just show a lot more gameplay or
something I wouldn't say a lot I think
I'll show a little bit that's not the
sort of game that they're going to try
to convince a new audience of buying
that they're selling that to the
audience that is already planning on
buying it yeah I think so yeah I mean
they'll make an appearance I bet do you
think SuperMario Odyssey will actually
make it on December like they originally
planned or holiday season yeah yeah see
more of that aside from that uh the
switch what was it is the most we've
seen from that first switch direct there
was someone had some off-screen footage
from an event in China recently
oh my one I haven't seen that yeah its
brief and it's at a weird angle with a
mild lighting on the screen but I guess
you get a look at some other
environments that we haven't sold oh
cool um I'll be interesting I'm really
excited for that
I totally oh man I think I'm hoping that
they announce a bundle as well because
that's I'm holding off buying a switch
and Colada sees out because that's
that's the game I cannot wait to play
because it's like there was no Mario for
Wii U that was really like a mainline
Mario for me I thought what was
wondering were you 3d what were Al and
3d when was the famous yeah yeah and
that was really good but it wasn't like
galaxy it wasn't a sunshine it wasn't
like you know did something crazy new
that's super mario makers those cat
suits were creepy um and yeah so Odyssey
just looks oh man
Conway you didn't put much of a Mario
maker no I didn't I didn't but I also
think that that is a sure thing yes -
how surely it has - but I'm a little
worried by the 3ds port that came out
only a few months ago they really
bungled that it they actually killed the
idea that that made Mario maker so great
which is the fact that you could share
levels with everyone yeah definitely
you could only share levels of people on
your friends list yeah just like it was
all really odd how do you think the
switch port of Mario maker would work as
well the way you had the stylus and
everything how they use for the switch
just with your own finger with your
buildings ad finger built-ins
yes stylish God gave you I think you've
said that exact thing and I asked that
exact question oh that's right that is
Pete Pete asked me to use my stylus
what are you talking about all right
getting on to firebomb Heroes they
announced that as well the switch do you
think they'll show a lot of that uh
maybe yeah I would hope so
I mean the fire was pretty big for them
so I wouldn't be too shocked yeah what
about that Shin Megami Tensei that's
what I was thinking of you kind of call
me it was distracted by that that's what
I really want to see I think we're gonna
see that more from atlas than Nintendo
frankly but like on their own separate
thing at their booth at their booth yeah
yeah that makes sense
I'm into that now persona 5 was my first
persona so no yeah very different you
like a few hours of foreign couldn't get
into it 120 hours of persona 5 later I'm
like that damn game yeah not to be
reductive and say they're very similar
just persona being an offshoot of Shin
Megami Tensei and I'm looking at what
Shin Megami Tensei is gets me interested
in it yeah I mean the the last one on 3d
s is still an amazing game that people
should play but yeah it's the 25th
anniversary for the series
maybe it'll miss you three and we'll see
it at TGS instead but I think III is the
right time do you have still talking
about Nintendo you have any like crazy
dreams I think I a lot of probably say
Metroid right yeah but I'm not holding
my breath yeah I I just don't see it
happening I'd love it to happen but it
always comes up every year as well
everyone always thinks that's what retro
is gonna do but in Metroid has just
never been a game that sells a lot you
know sells well enough like even Metroid
Prime did well but yeah after the first
one it kind of didn't I uh you know what
I think I'm gonna go crazy here maybe
some Mario Kart DLC yeah maybe
good lobbies maybe some a splatoon - a
splatoon trance will be amazing oh man
yeah I'd be so stoked for that
so anything Smash Bros related at this
point I reckon Smosh is gonna arrive
that's inevitable it's probably more
likely oh yeah I mean if not you know in
the next six months on I reckon early
next year it's a good time for them to
bring it out it's gonna be a system
sella and I think I would be surprised
if they attend I want to put that off
any more than they have to do you guys
think they'll show any new IPs for
Nintendo I hope that would be the time
to strike right with a switch doing
pretty well
I feel like third-party does have had
time now to kind of like take in the
switch see that people are actually
gonna pick it up and maybe that has like
tempted people into creating games and
having time to you know announcement
sure but yeah from Nintendo I'd be very
sure any arms is kind of a level for
them yeah and they have to go as far
with yeah they have to go as far like
they did with arms and with splatoon
right they're not just gonna pick
something out of their hat and give it a
try
so I'd be shocked if they really have
even the manpower to make something like
that right now at that scale for a brand
new IP yeah totally
anything else in Tendo related if I
close a segment out nah man I love
Nintendo I love the way the UH
Nintendogs it clicks when you put the
jerk on him yeah it's great
it's fantastic I looking forward to
breath of the wild dlc as well yes
hopefully it does drop down yeah maybe I
will
cool all right so I was Nintendo Ubisoft
what we expect what we hope to see you
can catch both those press conferences
on GameSpot twitch YouTube from our
channels we will be covering those two
important post shows we're doing a lobby
I'll talk more about that later but uh
right now just McDonald Dan crowd and we
have to kick you off and fortunately
thanks so much for coming a lot of you
for having us
yeah yeah yeah you'll see you'll see
these two over our e3 stages and will
not stop doing that
all right so gonna get into the last two
Microsoft and stone you're gonna have
Lucy James and tomorrow saying they're
coming on another two people from our UK
crew and we're going to get into that
right now our production manager Nick
margarita is bringing them on to the
stage here they are come behind me
tomorrow Hussein Lucy James what's going
on
you wore that you both got that shirt -
a little bit Russell Mike yeah I do what
was your what was the intention wearing
these Russell me specifically yes just
general not to be nice like that Russell
yeah yeah we make a t-shirt every year
just as like a team thing yeah so last
year was goose cuz everything's pretty
goose
yeah just replace the word good with
goose yeah why cuz it's fun okay
well not really with that video that one
guy said like that's pretty good
and then he didn't finish it for you
might like your brother got a long
origin story yeah another year before
that was Kanye spot yeah hit up
Konyaspor calm yeah is it still like
it's still live you direct about one
picture of Kanye West smiling which is
very rare on the internet but that he
smiles yeah yeah did you take the photo
I didn't take the photo no about games I
was standing in front of him so I can
only presume that he was smiling because
you saw me yeah yeah oh [ __ ] that's
tamura-san he's a damn dude that's the
UK I see that guy right he story one
time duh
alright well thank you for coming out
we're gonna talk to Microsoft and Sony
we're gonna get to Sony first alright ah
yeah we're kind of running long long run
yeah whatever its e3 pre e3 week yeah
Electronic Entertainment Expo
extravaganza efore you might say you
fully right here okay I get you um sweet
so let's get it to Sony what you guys
what you guys think it's so psvr how
much of a presence will that have I
think it will have a lip service
presence which is unfortunately gonna be
real yeah they're gonna I think they're
gonna smooth you know it's every time a
game comes out for it it gets this like
increase in interest because the games
are generally okay like quite good for
point is decent reso 7179 VR is awesome
really good and obviously we've got some
VR projects on the way fallout for
example so I expect there might be
enough presents for developers that
currently have VR projects in production
to feel like they're not being cut loose
but it might be just that and not much
more personally I would like to see more
of your stuff especially after resi but
whether we get it yeah I'm hoping we'll
get some like a full more full games a
lot of the things we've been getting
I've just felt like experiences or like
after thoughts like the the battlefront
one where you in X oh yeah um I feel
like they've sort of made the ground
work and they've shown that it's a it
can work and can be successful and I
just hope that they kind of don't put it
on the back burner
I hope yeah yeah I think they really
need to encourage developers obviously
it's going to defer it to really take
off is somebody's going to have to
connect with developers and encourage
them is like what they did with Resident
Evil right they provided an incentive to
to Capcom to do that and that probably
is a lot of that is financial right they
probably took a lot of the hit on that
so they need to do that more with other
third-party developers and if that
happens this year and if you see loads
of like third-party studios coming out
with VR projects that are a little more
substantial I think people who own one
and Sony phones will generally feel a
little bit better about their purchase
if you don't personally I'd be taking
that as like might be time to offload
this while it's a novel ESO you know
people who are still kind of interested
in it will buy it for a second-hand
price so yeah do you think Sony will
benefit a lot from going like hard in on
games because of Microsoft Scorpio
announcement everything clearly you know
like with the ps4 Pro and the slim in
the VR all came out last year Sony
doesn't really have like a hardware
announcement this year unless something
comes out of nowhere but you know with
Microsoft having Scorpio the show do you
think Sony will just focus hard on games
I mean that's worked for them in the
past
yeah yeah I could see them doing that my
question is just what what are those
games you know like in recent years it's
been new stuff this has been a lot of
surprises things we didn't see coming
but there's so many out there that still
haven't been released so it makes me
wonder how can they pay attention to
those games while also rolling out new
stuff this might actually be a little
bit more of a lukewarm year for Sony at
e3 when I think in the recent past
they've really killed it yeah because so
many of the things that we talk about
when we're talking about Sony this year
are kind of not really close to the
horizon at all I mean they mentioned
earlier that that God of War will be
making appearance Jeff Healey announced
that he's doing an hour-long panel kind
of three Colosseum thing with God of War
and the big thing with that is they've
painted the big image of it but it's
missing a segment of it so it has Kratos
his kid and but there's something
missing least it could be released a it
could be a dog on xbox well another game
with a dog or something does seem to be
a challenge I think I think like we put
a video up about how what Sony can do to
kind of win a press conference or win
III and I think a lot of people brought
up the point that they need to really
focus on delivering on their promises
because they're starting to build a
reputation of promising big things and
then those things vanishing for ages
Shenmue came out and was a big deal the
of dreams and we've seen next as its
come to be known yeah we've seen next to
nothing of it everything we have seen is
like postage stamp kind of looks like a
ps3 game same with Final Fantasy we've
seen Final Four they announced that and
then we've seen very little of it and
anything but this is all got to do more
with the publishers and like it's
classic spikes join right announcer yeah
and we'll never see it but even based
off of that like the problem they have
is even though the balls in the party
and publishers caught caught with that
if they build on the trend of announcing
these crazy you know Fantasy titles and
never actually delivering on them
they're going to build that reputation
of being like we're kind of just giving
you what you want to hear instead of
what you actually want to play and and
that could be dangerous I think again we
know is coming out soon in August
Uncharted The Lost Legacy mm-hmm
you guys excited for that yeah I am I
like uncharged tried for great so I'm
not thinking yeah yeah you wanna talk
about parade tomorrow don't it's
exciting oh man all right uh yeah I'm
excited too Chloe Fraser yeah I did miss
her yeah yeah yeah I was like I love ya
it seems like a very like full lengthy
game right at first yeah thought it
might have been DLC French IRA for when
they first showed it well a lot of
people also thought this was a lara
croft when they first showed it but yeah
i assume they'll show a lot more gear
and maybe not a lot more but they'll
show gameplay with this game releasing
what like two months after e3 yeah yeah
I'm excited to see what else they do
with it I mean for all the things that I
dislike what I really like about
uncharted 4 as a characterization again
the fact that they're going with these
two you know kind of no Xplode fully
characters is really exciting to me they
have a blank canvas now almost we've had
you know Drake for ages and the
characters that kind of orbit around him
are also kind of like based on his
history as opposed to their own in a lot
of ways these two characters are an
opportunity to kind of draw a line
between Drake and his you know gang of
friends and start something interesting
with these brand new characters almost
and really show us why they matter to
the world overrun try it what about a to
move from uncharted what about
insomniacs the amazing spider-man game
I am very excited about that huge spider
spider-man - yeah I mean the last time I
did it was sunset overdrive right yeah
yeah it's the same crepe director right
yeah well that's not the last game they
did they did as in stereo by oh the
creative director right here say yeah
which was a lost game with Carrie where
was sunset overdrive so and the magic
thing oh no where was good yeah what's
up what's um it's kitty I said trying
for a Russell here this is my teacher
rustling but like the great thing about
that game was movement around a city it
was really novel it felt good it felt
almost like you know games like infamous
and that kind of stuff like it's like
they combine Tony Hawk with Ratchet and
Clank
exactly so if there's a jet set radio or
jet sorry yes if there's one thing I'm
confident about now it's that they know
how to do movement really well and you
know I'm also super interested in kind
of like who that spider-man is and you
know what kind of university exists in
and how it fits into the Marvel Universe
whether this is something that is going
to be developed into a wider gaming
Marvel Universe like I'm super excited
about that I hope they don't do that
though I just want this to be a good
standalone spider-man yeah yeah
especially now that you've got Square
and I just making other Marvel games
it's probably very unlikely that they're
gonna cross over because they're IP and
yeah he owns what at this point good
point carved up like a Christmas turkey
really there is that is that a British
thing we have to kick ass
we don't have Thanksgiving so oh right
we have to get our doll meet at another
point in gotcha on the bandwagon just
clarify for tchen --it that you need to
say that you don't have Thanksgiving
yeah we should let you go without saying
but I should know I knew I'm just afraid
no I'm we have it we have it like and as
a novel but it's in July but you know
January don't you do this to me that
doesn't don't do this to me
um all right what about days gone which
we saw last year at e3 this is Amba
gainsaid show it that again well man I'm
gonna sound super cynical but I don't
understand like this the incredible hype
around that game when it first debuted I
was like it looks real good but you're
showing the crash zombie yeah you're
showing me as
the survival game with a Norman Reedus
Walking Dead characters what they look
like what's what's what's the hook here
what am i yeah
what am i look at excited I can tell he
is agreeing with me or saying like I'm a
green way okay I think I think at the
point out I'm a little burned out on
zombies you can be very burned out it's
yeah and it's kind of like it's it's
from what they showed like it looked
impressive like the sheer number of
zombies they have running on that screen
was I mean like that's probably not the
fun I hate that he rides a motorcycle I
hate that Norman Reedus of character
Rasmus like on The Walking Dead that's
why I stopped watching it six seasons
ago we all ride a motorcycle when
they're attracted to noise right a
bicycle you read any job survival
handbook yeah oh my god oh there's
another bike I should add that to my
Armada let's go okay but inside the
Pacific north yeah um I want to see more
about don't want to you know yeah
completely cut off before we've really
seen any yeah yeah it's kind of sorry
sorry Bilardo 11 in the twitch chat does
that drive a Prius yeah no idea it looks
like it could be fun maybe if they do
take I don't know it let me do something
like so the look of it like the
scavenging and stuff it's yeah it's more
like Last of Us meats dead rising it's
yeah it's just like hey let's get the
big - it's the thing about a is its
riding a wave like the some survival
games are hot right now there everyone
yeah it is so hot right now and I like
play unknown backgrounds that kind of
stuff you know
h1z1 or the other types of survival
games that this could be an incredibly
the thing that those have in common is
they're all like early access you know
kind of kind of thing like they have
these rough edges if like this developed
by Sony Bend and the last economy but
they they contribute to a lot of
Uncharted games up until now they do the
the vo yeah they I think they did a
little bit golden Abyss and they've been
working on more uncharged stuff so if
they come out with a really polished
survival game that console players can
you know get on board with I think that
has the potential to do well my current
kind of thinking is it feels very plain
there's no hook to it there's I mean the
day/night cycle I guess but there's like
there was the survival game that if a
day/night cycle is your hooks and that's
yes I need something more like it needs
to be something more substantial but
then like you look at something like
player unknown battlegrounds and it's
super simple it's you know there's not
much crazy mechanics to it and it's
currently the biggest game in the world
if you look at on Steam so you know just
doing something simple right could be
enough and there's nothing quite like
this on consoles so it might be they
just play safe and you know go for the
easy win
so yeah Lucy you mentioned The Last of
Us do you think we'll see much of the
Last of Us to this year yeah I reckon
that like that open or close
gameplay or no yeah yeah you got the
teaser with Ellie and Joel forget was
that PSX they show that off I believe so
yeah the other thing is like how
relevant is III for Sony anymore because
they have PSX it could be that if
Microsoft they're gonna Microsoft gonna
have a massive year and Sony might not
feel as much pressure to have a big year
because they have their own event where
they're gonna be sent to stage
yeah later on yeah yeah I'm excited to
see more last month - I didn't
originally want a sequel at all I
thought that game was very very good on
its own and just ended in seal had put
it away but now that I've seen Ellie the
fact that Joel seemed kind of nervous
around her and that teaser asking her
what her end game was with killing all
these people and the fact that she's
clearly gonna grow up to be messed up
I'm excited to see what they do with her
because she was the draw of the Last of
Us for me yeah yeah I'm really excited
for that I want see more guitar playing
yeah I just wanna say that if they if it
is the same as like you're going round
as a - gotta fix that AI ya fix that
can't have gonna have characters walking
in front of enemies and being like no no
one CNN wants through then in some KS
she's tattooed herself since yeah yes
great work she uh did she do that
herself
sticking oh yeah Wow thank you that Joel
do - Justin um alright
what about Gran Turismo sport yeah I'm
excited for that yeah yeah Oh Miguel
later Miguel did a demo recently right
Miguel concepción here I redditor um
super like simulation have you write
these work yeah
I'm just gonna go like Gran Turismo
games always have problems you know I
look at something like for it supports
our horizon like those games seem to be
improving like every time but they're
improving on something that's already
great
I don't think Gran Turismo is going to
be a better game or even a game that's
as good but it certainly speaks to like
my nostalgia as someone who grew up
watching the series evolve um in odd
ways to like I love how far up his own
ass the guy at polyphony digital is
we're creating regards to his work on
the series it's just super weird it's a
weird racing series but yeah there's a
lot of depth that you can explore in
terms of customizing your car learning
how to race and a wide array of you know
different racing types yeah I think it's
going to be interesting to see how this
game does because racing game fans these
kind of simulation tiles are like you
said they're few and far between right
yeah I mean Gran Turismo also has a
history of including in arcade mode in a
lot of their games so it might not be
just hardcore simulation I think if
they're smart they're going to have
something for both camps yeah
and so between this and the crew 2 or
the other racing games it'll be at e3
project car project yeah be nice you see
yeah you see payback mmm nice Oh zero
what No
don't do this that's never gonna just
make yourself sad no it's like it's
interesting I want to see how Gran
Turismo performs especially against
these other contenders who sort of also
been around for a while but have really
made sure to hang on into the public
consciousness recently like Gran Turismo
is the name that everyone knows but it
hasn't been around for and six was a
mess I don't know if you guys played six
five was really really good on
PlayStation 3 but six became all about
microtransactions to the point that
purchasing cars in the game was forcing
your hand to spend real money and it was
[ __ ] crash D racing to never know
yeah you never do that's true we must've
just shown any comes out with a Crash
Team Racing teacher all right let's move
on to some speculation uh do you think
res able to remake will show up yes yeah
you think it's gonna show up yes okay
gameplay or just yes
already um yeah it seems like it would
be a good time to do it right Resident
Evil has been back on the map like
positive people really liked resonable 7
now would be a time to come out with
oh here's thing you've been waiting for
and also do you think it'll be faithful
to resin evil to like just like remake
was the resonable one I think it will be
I think they're going to try and keep it
close like you know introduce the modern
trimmings that people like the more
direct controls but I think a continued
human intervention whatever is cool but
the rest of it is going to be fairly
like truthful to the classic I think
that's how most fans want it yeah no
probably what they'll do is they'll go
oh hey here's the Resident Evil 7 DLC
dekat the late rhotic you know yeah now
let's have a look at yeah a lot of the
things they were telling you guys when
you were talking to them earlier this
year was a late last year it was got a
this year earlier this year I mean it
sounds like they have a very keen
understanding of what Resident Evil is
and even the miss you know the
quote-unquote miss steps they made those
those weren't accidents necessarily it
was a different direction for the series
that they've since decided to avoid yeah
those those were yeah those were
measured full-out decisions rat they
were confused about what people wanted
they won't cover giant yeah they're
trying to make dolla dolla bill yo yeah
did they did it for a while and they
kind of like did it to the point where
everyone was like we don't want this
anymore right rolled it back and hit
something good if you're wondering what
this is this is a show that I do every
once a while with former producer Mary
Kish resident Knievel we're going
through all the Resident Evil games and
this was - if you're wondering why she
just got destroyed by like every Basanti
nope against because that was her first
time playing it ah so don't judge that
ya skin was one of my favorite Resident
Evil cause there guy in the truck is
like guy's a maniac why'd he bite me
that's really good some exposition on
let's see if she gets caught by anybody
yep yeah I think she dies I'm going to a
sea station there's guys no no no no no
meanwhile I'm just drinking watching her
but we run resignify were now playing
co-op we're actually almost done of it
but anyway yeah I actually think remake
- we'll be there - um is Marion the
cherry now what do you laughs knows
someone's saying I guess they're
skipping over Bandai Games because they
didn't mention you know Cooney - very
glad to see you know - you know Cooney -
coming
yeah but Bandai is not Sony or Nintendo
yeah oh yeah just be clear with
Playstation you think you know I get no
what I'm saying is Bandai we're not
bringing up a Bandai section yeah yeah
sorry I seriously of course here you
think okay do you think Neal Cooney -
we'll be at the Sony Prescott yes yeah
yeah yeah um I would like to see it I
like the first one actually I played
about half of it never got to finish it
because it was long I never finished
because it was so grinding it's noisy
hmm yeah bang tiny tiny see I'd like to
see ninokuni - it's only yeah um all
right some more hello
here's a time yes here's my here's my I
know you know I know you blood-borne -
well buy it this woman who knows no no
no no I don't know like obviously it
would make perfect sense for blood-borne
two to exist but really a really good
photo shop yesterday I would hundred
percent play that I would play - our
main Gascoyne awesome dude I would be a
be Michael ash me : I taught that would
be his giant head over it makes perfect
sense for a blood-borne two to exist
whether it happens who knows like I feel
like the thing that's kind of making me
say maybe it might notice because from
software you know when the izaki took
control and became president his thing
was i'm going to try and diversify and
try and create as much as possible and
the thing that is kind of lending some
weight to the idea that something from
software related could appear a three is
the image of Shuhei Yoshida having a
meal with Miyazaki and and then I don't
know how recently it was the writer of
sci-fi series the expanse revealed that
he had worked with from software on
something and we've heard Miyazaki say
that there's a sci-fi thing bye-bye
thing in the works yeah yeah so it could
be I think it's more likely that we'll
get something new from from software
don't starboard yeah
nobody's ever become a to project studio
yeah which is another likely thing they
could do because yeah I mean they've
done it before so yeah I'd be happy I'd
really love the idea of a blood-borne
two but I also feel like it's perfect as
it is like leave it on its own
yeah and that's when the game developers
do though there's since winners like I
feel like if anyone knows the value of
watering down something that people read
what happens when you water down
something that people really love it's
from software Docs I was one incredible
about those two yeah it's gotta the
first thing was like so it helped
somewhat similar thing of Armored Core
either Oh exactly how much more so yeah
I think they know what happens they know
the pitfalls of continually returning to
and I feel like Miyazaki would be he's
in a position now where he can demand
not to have that right and and like the
idea of a new thing from from software
is more enticing to platform holders and
publishers than a sequel to something
else because they know that whenever
these guys think of something new it's
incredible and people go mad for it so I
have feeling like if a Sony came up to
him and was like we want something new
from you that seems like the thing that
is likely to happen so yeah maybe any
last minute so many things before we
move onto Microsoft oh man we're gonna
get horizon DLC yeah yeah that makes
sense it might be here it seems like
it's late but it also could be all wait
a minute yeah - oh don't do it
we forgot here we go
get that heart knack to footage why let
it roll you know would be amazing if
this came out and it was like genuinely
brilliant yeah yeah everyone's just like
God we have to care about knack now and
at the end the crew the credits is just
a big middle finger and yeah nobody's
named it's just an actual jpeg of mark
Cerny with his middle finger or like how
you like me now haha
yeah I'm so yeah a knack to this this is
my I'm pumped for this more than
anything for the show is that Russell
that's a rose that's awesome guys I
don't wanna yeah I don't know
Nick margarita I think it's pretty
pumped is nice I would be it looks
pretty good uh yeah sorry he's probably
gonna bust through the studio you've got
to be like the hell are they talking
about yeah alright like dream dream if
on the NBR on none unknown a dream my
dream announcement I know sorry I guess
what reboot medium oh I saw let's go out
there deny Media Molecule noise way it
was Joe but like this is never gonna
happen but for God's sake someone make a
new Legacy of Kain game I don't care who
it is just do it Soul Reaver new cane
hope Sony somewhere is in like one
person cares about this let's put some
money forward people are talking about
until dawn to in the chat do you think
that will happen
now was it who dies me dead supermassive
yeah yeah again I think that that game
was alone like surprisingly good mmm-hmm
like not surprising agonizing that years
better than we thought but it's like oh
my god this is actually really good and
people don't buy yeah like no I don't
think it's something really well but it
was great and also like they immediately
like pooed on its legacy by releasing
that hot dumpster fire of a VR
experience so think about how long it
must have been in development for cuz it
start off yeah move game on the ps3
right so it's not gonna make what about
anything from Sucker Punch it's related
oh yeah they have been quiet for a while
and I don't have to do something
infamous related I think they'll do
something new again I think infamous had
its moment on the ps3 but I feel like
its legs outside of it hasn't been
do you like second son I like second
sentence okay I thought was really
beautiful and a good showcase of the and
the DLC was much bad in the original
game but I feel like that's where that
should be the full stop on this agnya
infamous and
problem with him from a second son was
that like the effects and everything
were fantastic and gorgeous when you had
the neon and everything but the city
itself was dry infamous hardly fun I
liked I liked the relationship you had
with the main guy and his brother and
when you have such command I liked all
that but I felt they focus really hard
on making those things good and
everything else just like the mission
structure was boring and yeah just doing
the same thing over and over again and
me collecting drones and yeah not into
it all right let's put Sony in the
backburner move on Microsoft obviously
the big thing is Scorpio yeah that's
gonna be the big presence um I they've
also said there's no halo 6 at the show
but there might be something for Halo
fans don't have any idea what that would
be yeah the walls three boys hey Laura
sorry remaster don't get away you'll be
awesome actually come to think of it
that I didn't think about is for if they
actually added reach to the Master Chief
collection cuz that's the one game it's
not know if that if that's an Ionian see
if that is the announcement people are
gonna be like I've seen people calling
for him it's weird to have not having in
there they added ODST with a DLC for
free people not it mmm-hmm right do you
like him yeah I love halo yeah but I
don't kind of want to see more from
what's new and instead of like old stuff
here's the dev kit we saw Major Nelson
published a video yes I'm in Elsa blog
it's gonna be great yeah he published
that video that he was talking
interviewing one of the developers of
the dev kit just uh so that's a defecate
that's obviously not what the final
versions gonna look like hold the phone
like my Hardy hey so that looks green
right that seems like the one thing that
you would guess that's not going to be
on there but I read this little thing of
the day that you can actually program
little games for it which is like with
it what is the point of that if not at
some point this is going to be a little
gimmick that is out there just to make
it look a little bit weird and
interesting yeah free after those one
you know those wonder ways Tom at the
FPS 60 thing that's actually like a
digital screen that's definitely a
nothing it's a system seller but it'd be
kind of neat to have like an equalizer
on there you could set it to run I think
nothing will be cool is obviously the
Xbox current Xbox when you turn it off
it does background downloads and that
kind of stuff you're just how
all their information they're like
what's downloading what's ready what's
notification or like your internet
connection disrupted yeah just turn it
back on and yes have like the kind of
extra information that you'd want to get
and but not necessarily have to turn the
thing on to have it be just a neat
little facet yeah
so without halo showing up at halo 6
showing up at e3 as Microsoft has said
and nothing about like a new Gears of
War yet like their two flagship
franchises I would say um maybe kids
eSports my other baby [ __ ] I think I
just had a pretty big guy again right
here's more for just had a pretty big
DLC release recently like one of their
bigger ones but uh the big question mark
because the scorpio looks really
appealing and i'm hoping that you know
like it takes off but what games does it
have to support it right now so that's
what I'm hoping and you would assume
they would go for at e3 right like
crackdown yeah don't cry you don't know
what we know about right cuz Scallon got
cancelled uh you know like no halo 1 I
want to know the story behind that yes
so bad rip um but yeah crackdown 3 do
you think we'll finally have more info
on it because of what they first
announced it how many years ago - two
years ago yeah I mean and then I was um
was it a Gamescom it was like behind
closed doors and they were showing off
the cloud processing destruction yes and
it was incredibly impressive yeah it was
super cool um uh so I think probably
that's gonna be there yeah I think when
we saw at Gamescom that was the extent
of what they had like they can make
these buildings collide and do crazy
things but the game around it hadn't
kind of formed there was yeah there was
nothing that was new about it yeah it
was just crack down and destructible
environment I think it has a especially
with you know the main focus of
Microsoft's you know press conference is
going to be what they're saying is like
you know it's the most powerful console
around and what you know this is the
perfect game to show it off you make the
entire city fold in on itself and go
look it hasn't exploded the console
still they're all good and people go you
see that bit where the city folding on
itself best console that's what they
want right but but the trick is going to
be is that it's not going to be locally
processed right it's still going to be
cloud-based
so it'll play just the same on your xbox
one presumably well it's not yeah it's
not harnessing the hardware right right
yeah but I mean you know the rest of the
game and everything that will run on
Scorpio will no doubt run better than on
the original Xbox one it's just this
example yeah could be used as sort of
like a like a facade almost yeah yeah
we'll see I think it's really
interesting I think this is gonna be the
most interesting the press conference
not only because they have a new bell
hardware but what do they the first
party their backs against the ropes seem
right now I do want to get to
third-party games because I think that's
where they could benefit with the
Scorpio but last one
cuphead people finally see it out this
year I hope so yeah I'm enthusiastic
about the fact that they're building
actual like levels it's not just boss
battles now yeah so you know that's the
reason it was delayed as far as I can
tell that's good yeah I think that needs
to be a release date this year yeah yeah
I mean it was just like hand is really
hard is really difficult and Jon like
what's your animation yeah it looks
really good I played it like three years
in a row and I don't know when it's
coming out but um yeah another sea of
thieves rares what is it pirate mm oh
yeah I came just look fun though it does
I could be cool Nick margarita was just
playing the Alpha last weekend and I
guess he would he would be the one to
ask what his thoughts on it but it does
seem cool over the last I played it at
e3 last year but it was only the team
deathmatch naval warfare kind of thing
it was fun having each person fell out a
role on the ship but yeah I'm curious to
see it's such a weird departure for rare
I mean rares not what it used to be
obviously like when we think of rare I
think I think of like banjo kazooie I
think of metal so then the connect is
yeah yeah I think this is a game this
game is partly to reinvent itself as
something new and try and not cut off
his legacy but like draw a line under it
and try and become something yeah that
people care about again instead of this
thing that people look back on fondly
and not really pay attention to what
they're doing now and almost outright
just write them off so I'm really
interested in seeing what waver comes
and from what I've played and seen of it
it's fun you can get drunk and fall off
a boat pepper about that life for me
they need to show me more of like how
it's going to work overall because I've
seen a little snippet
but then I know the Alpha was the actual
open world treasure hunting and they
seem to be that that seems to be a big
focus but and then of course you can
like actually be pirates and seeing
other people ships take their treasure
combine treasure maps I'm curious what
the overall structure will feel like is
that in an open world game is pretty
important to me yeah yeah I'm curious
what they'll show but yeah I think with
barring any other new like surprise new
IPs or like sequels that they announced
for the Scorpio I think they would you
know they'd be remiss they didn't focus
on third party games and people are
excited about on the Scorpio saying this
is the best way to play you know Far Cry
5 or Sanskrit origins or destiny 2 even
though that's pretty heavily supported
by Sony I don't know do you think that's
the best strategy going forward from
Microsoft this year it's the best thing
that they have going for them right now
yeah yeah yes there's nothing else they
have I don't think it's a great strategy
I don't think it's exciting to be coming
out and saying like hey this is the best
place to play games yeah when people are
like I'm kind of cool with my other
console right now so you're not really
selling me no and I valuably PC is yes
to agency is always gonna be the best
way to play any game that's more
platform and I mean you have like some
people loyal to like their ps4 you have
people who have Xbox ones and really
like Microsoft but you don't know
whether to upgrade then you have like
you just said the PC crowd which doesn't
have a problem Bishop II the strategy 2
should be to provide experiences that
cannot be played anywhere else instead
of trying to be like here's the thing
that is available there but it's a
little bit better here right because you
get an extra bit content yeah even even
like it's even exclusive DLCs is not
gonna sell people on buying a brand-new
expensive console no yeah that would be
like yeah it's time to exclusive great
for you I'll just weigh it out there's
plenty of game watch people playing
Zelda watch people playing you know neo
or near and it's just like well I guess
I'll keep my fingers crossed for Halo
like I don't ya know speed up
third-party games before we kind of
close the show out are there any come to
top ahead at the top of your head that
you're really excited for Lucy what is
it it's gonna be on yeah just ones we
might not have touched no not necessary
Microsoft just the whole show in general
cuz we've been sticking mainly the first
party stuff uh I'm excited for
Assassin's Creed
yeah that person who's to please
everyone even though it's I mean cuz
it's I'm excited because they've taken a
year off and if it is the ancient Egypt
setting yes please
running up the side of a pyramid is
gonna be yeah yeah there's a kid I used
to want to be an Egyptologist yeah yeah
I was gonna like his I should go see the
mummy I hear it's awesome to meet you
bill what's the night vision
oh is it Fraser Brendan Fraser oh yeah
you know movie he's better in but
Desmond see no oh my god but yeah so
that's the second time someone's
mentioned bedazzle today it was like the
sixth time I met so accessory origins of
Mark such as Creed origins is a big one
for me as well I love the idea of being
in Egypt I want to see what Metal Gear
survived is don't do this because I know
I know that it's not gonna be what I
want but I want Heat what do you want to
see I want that definitive I basically
want someone to tell me okay
you can definitely stop caring about Mel
gana you can just just move on with your
life yeah well interestingly enough on
the Kili panel with Kojima
the director of the middle of your movie
is gonna be there alright wait Jordan
for others did and you can come okay yes
right hey sorry his name yeah yeah yeah
eluded me but yeah for Roberts yes but
the big beer Oh Kevin yeah yeah what are
you excited to see that we're from
Microsoft just anybody third-party game
just anybody that we might not attached
on man I don't know it's always a big
question mark for me I'm Carrie I don't
want to see the surprises I am real
interested in Scorpio I want to see what
the final product looks like but more
importantly the price hmm III would like
to see everyone succeed and that
includes Microsoft if this is like a
$600 console I I'll be really
disappointed
mmm but that'll depends on because said
they are blaring those lines between
Xbox and PC more more and more if it is
something that I could if I could use
the Scorpio as a PC in a week that's
been the way that's been the dream for
years and if they're if they pull that
off I would absolutely love that and I
would be to the gym really so excited
about it but it would depend on how they
how they do it and I'm yeah I this is
the most excited I've been for Microsoft
press conference for
yeah yeah they've kind of screwed up the
Xbox games anywhere wherever the hell
was called like there were a couple
anyway yeah there were a couple games
are like save files didn't work that the
release timing wasn't quite there and
not everyone agreed to it today no and
that was the thing as they kind of
misled people because they said from now
on every exclusive or not every source
of it they said [ __ ] every Xbox game
will be but right the caveat was every
Xbox game we showed during the show this
year will be like it's a big about-face
and it's kind of strange um the other
big thing is I make sure I should see
how Bioware or what happens with Bioware
could rumored IP forgotten else what did
Dylan Dylan yeah dialog we talked about
this earlier but like I don't know if
it's gonna appear but like then again
Mass Effect Andromeda came oh and it was
now the safest thing for them to do
would take some time yeah yeah but I get
the feeling Megan people are kind of
thinking what is Bioware right now and
if they came out were like hey there's a
snippet of this new thing that we're
working on that might be enough to kind
of like recover some of that negative
Center or recover the Mass Effect memes
and have those dummy yes I mean it
dominate the conversation fine
yeah there's a really interesting not to
pimp another site but no I'm good Taku
there's a really interesting long-form
feature right now about the problems
that were you know present during the
development of NGO Moana obviously a
different studio from the rest of the
bio channel but yeah yeah
and also Nintendo obviously plenty of
stuff coming from them Mario's gonna be
a big guys yeah yeah and yeah I want to
see what more switch stuff yeah don't
want no the Pokemon Russell
yeah that's horse that popular also was
tena attend Russell jet LAG's go up at
six o'clock to cover it here's an
old-ass Pokemon for an old asking
console I'm excited for Wolfenstein 2 if
that does become a thing and shadow of
war I just want see more shadow 4 even
though it's releasing I got pushback
what October Tony Oni yeah yeah but I'm
looking forward to seeing more that
because I'm really excited for you son
we played it yeah you play I'm actually
playing the first one of the minute it's
real want the jump is is can you're
replaying shadow mortar right now yeah
yeah if you like what that game that's
like kind of working in there if you
like mechanics that game is full of them
like layers and layers and layers
stuff you like damn there's also the we
were talking about it earlier while
we're watching you guys talk about the
Fez de tolly there's a is that one
bethesda project that taught how has
been working on for ages that he's
talking about Starla right there no
separate one I think is so stylish cross
shoulder it's called
beef people in a chat with fully rustled
by you calling a stylist so unusual that
never happened that's just Pete's thing
yeah Chandler I don't know if it's the
same thing but I think it's another
major project that he's been working on
for quite a long time but he's only
referred to it as a big thing that's
different from anything else that
they've ever shown it could be a good
time to Buffalo 4vr been put it in there
I was review RC all right we've gone for
like almost two hours longer you
expected but there's a lot to talk about
with e3 and of course we have our
friends from UK and Australia offices
over here it's been a fun show I just
saw elderly scrolls elders
sweet so as we announce the giveaway
winner earlier uh fit me no I believe
Derek for sake from Massachusetts if you
don't have that razor blade forty inch
laptop yet I took it
no it's kidding it's on its way uh but
yeah so thank you everybody for joining
in YouTube chat twitch chat and GameSpot
chat I do have a pretty cool
announcement we are going to be on the
coop stage doing a lobby episode
Wednesday morning almost a normal time
will be 11:30 Pacific it'll be Pete
Callie
Rob and I will be doing that and then of
course obviously will be doing pre and
post shows for all the big conferences
well I'll be on the stage we'll be doing
a lot of hands-on impressions and demos
throughout the whole next week obviously
is going to be crazy but we're looking
forward to it and we're heading down to
LA in a few days
so stay tuned the game spot we're gonna
be doing giveaways throughout the week
so if you don't follow games but on
Twitter make sure you do that just so
you can hear about that but also like
retweet us so you could be considered
for those giveaways Shiva will see you
and hopefully like Derrick pick you out
of the random bunch but as always thanks
for joining we'll be back next week see
you then
you